it's a long nine to ten months girl you
know you you have to enjoy it well those
nine or ten months are over and rihanna
is now enjoying motherhood yep the 34
year old singer gave birth to her first
child with beau asap rocky
it's amazing and i'm honestly truly
blessed real you know the couple
announced the news they were expecting
in january and at the time a source told
e.t riri and asap are over the moon
about becoming parents
explaining the two are feeling very
blessed that they're having a baby
together and that they already consider
themselves a family but having a baby
together makes that bond even stronger
she may never wear it but she save it so
our babies will be flyer than their
parents
and there's no doubt rhianna and asap's
kids will be as fly as their parents
when it comes to fashion the beauty
mogul slayed all the looks as she waited
for baby's arrival
like in this green sequin halter top she
wore a fenty beauty event in
but february are making it look so
stylish
you having fun with it well you have to
we're making it your fashion show i'm
trying to enjoy it as much as i could
and fashion is one of my favorite things
so
you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend
turns out asap's been there for re
during those uncomfortable times a
source told e.t he's been her rock
throughout the pregnancy
quote asap has been tending to all of
rihanna's needs and they are really
enjoying this moment together as a
couple
rihanna and asap have such a strong bond
and they can't wait to experience
parenthood together
what are you looking forward to as you
move into a new chapter of your life
i'm just excited for what i don't know
yet you know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited and as for what
kind of mom ree will be she told elle
she's looking to the real housewives for
inspo everyone just wants to be loved
and accepted at the base minimum it's
what your parents should be doing for
you rihanna says she'll probably be a
little like orange county's heather
dubrow all accepting of whatever her kid
wants to be
that's nothing compared to just being
there for them you know you're their
mommy or their provider you're you're
their everything and then fiercely
protective like new jersey's teresa
judice
teresa from new jersey does not play
about her kids she will flatten you
about those kids and that resonates with
me a lot
so now that the little one is here what
does that mean for rihanna's other baby
her music do you think this stage in
your life is going to inspire new music
oh gosh
you can't ever you know that's why my
fans love you you know because you asked
all the good questions
uh well
yes you're still gonna get music from me
maybe a lullaby i could see you and asap
dropping demos in the studio
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby i'd need to sleep with this
music they're like we are grown
yeah the navy will have to continue to
wait patiently for that as rihanna and
asap enjoy their new little bundle of
joy congratulations to the family of
three
[Music]
you